for a different context the words
of a president matter no matter how good
or bad that president is
at their best the words of a president
can inspire
at their worst they can incite
therefore i call on president trump
to go on national television now
to fulfill his oath and defend the
constitution
and demand an end to this siege
to storm the capitol to smash windows
to occupy offices the floor of the
united states senate
rummaging through desks on the capitol
on the house of representatives
threatening the safety of dually elected
officials it's not protest
it's insurrection
the world's watching like so many other
americans
am genuinely shocked and saddened that
our nation
so long the beacon of light and hope for
democracy
has come to such a dark moment
through war and strife america has
endured much
and we will endure here and we will
prevail again
and will prevail now the work of the
moment
and the work of the next four years must
be the restoration
of democracy of decency honor
respect the rule of law
just plain simple decency
the renewal of the politics it's about
solving problems looking out for one
another
not stoking the flames of hate and chaos
as i said america is about honor
decency respect tolerance
that's who we are that's who we've
always been
the certification electric colleague the
electoral college vote
supposed to be a sacred ritual which we
affirm
purposes to affirm the majesty of
american democracy
but today is a reminder a painful one
that democracy is fragile and to
preserve it
requires people of good will leaders
with the courage to stand up
who are devoted not to the pursuit of
power
or the personal interest pursuits of
their own selfish interest
at any cost but of the common good
i think when our children watching
television is thinking
think what the rest of the world is
looking at
for nearly two and a half centuries
we the people in search of a more
perfect union
ever kept our eyes on that common good
america is so much better than what
we're seeing today
watching the scenes from the capitol
i was reminded as i prepared other
speeches in the past and was reminded of
the
words of abraham lincoln and his annual
message to congress
whose work has today been interrupted by
chaos
here's what lincoln said
he said we shall nobly save or merely
lose
the last best hope on earth
went on to say the way is plain
peaceful generous just
a way which if followed
the world will forever applaud and god
must forever bless
the way is playing here too that's who
we are
is the way of democracy of respect
of decency of honor
and commitment is patrons to this nation
notwithstanding what i saw today we're
seeing today
i remain optimistic about the incredible
opportunities
there has never been anything we can't
do
when we do it together
and this god-awful display today
it's bringing home to every republican
and democrat and independent in the
nation
that we must step up this is the united
states of america there's never
ever ever ever ever been a thing we've
tried to do
we've done it together we've not been
able to do it
so president trump step up
god bless america may god protect our
troops
and all those folks at the capitol we're
trying to preserve order
thank you and i'm sorry to have kept you
waiting
today are you concerned about your
inauguration sir has already spoken to
mcconnell today
are you concerned about your
inauguration you're not violent
i am not concerned about my safety
security or the inauguration
i am not concerned the american people
are going to stand up
and stand up now enough is enough
is enough
you